[Música]
nueva jornada de protestas en Israel en
contra de la Reforma judicial los
manifestantes señalan que la ley
acabaría con la democracia israelí un
sistema cuestionado por varias
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos por
permitir la discriminación de ciudadanos
y la ocupación ilegal de territorios
palestinos
no hay tregua en Sudán y Arabia Saudita
evacúa a 50 nacionales y a decenas de
ciudadanos de países amigos desde
territorios sudanés hasta el puerto
saudí de jeda a través del mar Rojo
aunque se informó que las fuerzas
armadas sudanesas coordinaban la salida
de diplomáticos aún no hay información
al respecto
este sábado 22 de abril se celebra el
Día de la tierra una fecha que sirve de
advertencia de las graves consecuencias
de la crisis climática con un año 2022
especialmente cálido las metas para
proteger el planeta están lejos de
cumplirse
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
Israel porque allí avanza la jornada de
protestas número 16 en contra de la
Reforma del sistema judicial del
gobierno de extrema derecha los
opositores en la ley aseguran que
acabaría con la independencia de la
justicia al subyugar entre otras cosas
la Corte Suprema al parlamento y
destacan que favorecería la situación
del Primer Ministro Benjamín netanyahu
que enfrenta distintos procesos por
corrupción de momento la legislación
está pausada entre otras cosas debido a
la presión internacional de países como
Estados Unidos el propio Joe biden
advirtió a netanyahu que Israel no puede
permitirse perder su imagen de
democracia sin embargo varias
organizaciones de Derechos Humanos
señalan que la democracia israelí está
en entredicho desde que permite la
ocupación ilegal de territorios
palestinos y la discriminación de sus
ciudadanos no judíos
[Música]
lo que quiero decirle netanyahu Es que
tiene que ser un líder para todo el
pueblo de Israel no de la mitad del
pueblo que vota por él
porque actualmente está hablando con su
pueblo el pueblo que votó por él y los
demás no le importamos
ahora con información relativa la
situación en Sudán porque Arabia Saudita
logró las primeras evacuaciones de
civiles desde territorio sudanés con
barcos que cruzaron el mar rojo desde
las costas de Sudán hasta el puerto
saudí de jeda
riad sacó así a 50 nacionales y a
decenas de ciudadanos de países amigos
no especificados en Sudán el cuarto
acuerdo de ces el fuego alcanzado ayer
fracasó igual que los anteriores los
enfrentamientos entran ya en su segunda
semana y dejan más de 400 muertos
actualizamos la situación en jartum la
capital sudanesa con el siguiente
informe
las columnas de humo y el sonido de los
incesantes disparos dan cuenta de la
continuación de los combates en jartum
la capital sudanesa el alto al fuego de
tres días declarado el viernes por
motivo de las celebraciones de Late
parece haberse hecho añicos en la mañana
del sábado fuertes explosiones acudieron
la ciudad especialmente en este edificio
sede de un banco
refugiada desde su casa la exministra de
asuntos exteriores se pronunció
describió a harton como una ciudad
sumida en el caos
hay bombardeos a nuestro alrededor pero
no sabemos De dónde vienen
también Vimos a jóvenes uniformados han
tomado las calles creo que han tomado en
la zona donde vivimos
5 millones de personas viven en la
capital pero las calles están casi
desiertas la mayoría de los habitantes
no tienen agua ni electricidad Ahora son
Rehenes de una guerra por el poder en el
país entre dos generales el jefe del
ejército regular al buján y su antigua
Aliado ham dane dagglo el líder de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido una poderosa
milicia paramilitar la situación sigue
siendo confusa en terreno tanto en
jartum como en la ciudad vecina de ondon
escenario también de intensos combates
lo que impide por el momento evacuar a
los civiles los que intentan huir tienen
que pagar enormes sumas de dinero Los
tiquetes en la estación de autobuses son
demasiado caros llegué de abrir por la
mañana tuve que pagar 7000 libras
sudanesas pero para irme tengo que pagar
25.000 libras sudanesas el equivalente a
44 dólares es increíble hasta una
botella de agua cuesta 500 libras las
condiciones de vida aquí son muy
difíciles
un informe de la OMS todavía provisional
afirma que cientos de personas han
muerto y miles dan resultado heridas los
observadores piden que se tomen medidas
para evitar que se desate una guerra
civil en Sudán
en otras noticias el presidente de
Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
declaró querer unir los esfuerzos de los
países neutrales para mediar en una
salida negociada a la guerra en Ucrania
Lula diostas declaraciones en Lisboa en
el marco de su gira Portugal y España
con este viaje el presidente brasileño
mantiene su Apuesta por devolver Brasil
al escenario internacional luego del
aislamiento diplomático de su antecesor
Jair bolsonaro Brasil regresa Sí pero
con una posición que ha generado
molestia entre los occidentales es que
durante su visita china Lula acusó a la
Unión Europea y a Estados Unidos de
incentivar el conflicto en Ucrania
no quiero complacer a nadie solo quiero
encontrar una manera de traerlos a ambos
a la mesa parecía imposible pero sucedió
en la Segunda Guerra Mundial cuando
parecía que no iban a hablar y hablaron
no tienes que destruir el mundo para
encontrar la paz no tienes que
destruirlo
esta guerra no debería haber comenzado
Rusia no debería haber invadido pero
invadió
y el periódico New York Times reveló
este viernes que los documentos
confidenciales del pentágono circularon
por el portal de internet discord desde
febrero de 2022 cuando empezó la
invasión rusa de Ucrania una de las
principales conclusiones que se extrajo
de la filtración es que Estados Unidos
no confía del todo en el éxito de la
eventual contraofensiva de primavera
anunciada por Ucrania entre otras cosas
por falta de armamento a pesar del
incesante envío de ayuda militar
occidental previamente hablamos con
Fernando cocho analista de inteligencia
Y seguridad internacional sobre qué
necesita Ucrania para lanzar esta
esperada contraofensiva de primavera
el problema de la Guerra de Ucrania es
que se necesita una continua
aprovisionamiento de armas y logística
para poder enfrentarse al otro lado de
un país como Rusia que a pesar de sus
deficiencias a pesar de sus errores
cuenta con un potencial militar civil y
militar bastante avanzado para poder
crear la vuelta a este conflicto y poder
recuperar O al menos mantener una
estabilidad en el frontera del dowbas
necesitaría pues muchísima más armamento
y muchísima más preparación no están
preparados aún para manejar los tanques
leopard y para manejar del todo las
baterías antiaéreas que tienen y la
supremacía aérea y artillera que está en
Rusia tiene sobre Ucrania es manifiesta
por tanto necesitaría un apoyo decisivo
por parte de la otan cosa que implicaría
por tanto un enfrentamiento geopolítico
con con Rusia que en estos momentos está
dentro de la presidencia el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas por tanto
no contaría con el de la de la ONU y
sería algo muy arriesgado para Europa e
incluso para Estados Unidos
y en otros temas este sábado una
organización arqueológica marítima
australiana a yo los restos del
Montevideo Maru un barco japonés que
había sido hundido por un submarino
estadounidense durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial un ataque naval que causó la
muerte de más de mil personas la mayoría
soldados australianos que habían sido
tomados como prisioneros de guerra por
los japoneses
la tragedia marítima más grande de
Australia tendrá su cierre 81 años
después este sábado los encargados de la
búsqueda encontraron los restos del
Montevideo Maru una embarcación mercante
japonesa que fundida por submarinos
estadounidenses en 1942 durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en el mar de
China meridional una tragedia que dejó
alrededor de 1000 muertos de los cuales
864 eran prisioneros de guerra
australianos
esta tragedia supuso la mayor pérdida de
Vidas de australianos en el mar en
nuestra historia
desde entonces la ausencia de una
ubicación del Montevideo marú ha
representado una asignatura pendiente
para las familias de quienes perdieron
la vida hasta hoy cuando finalmente esas
familias tendrán unción
la búsqueda estuvo a cargo del grupo
arqueológico marítimo Silent foundation
una organización sin fines de lucro
especialista en aguas profundas y que
fue apoyada el departamento de defensa
Nacional los restos del barco
permanecerán en el fondo del mar y no se
retirarán cuerpos humanos por respeto a
las familias
estábamos haciendo un recorrido y la
máquina se quedó sin batería y en la
última vuelta que dio antes de que la
subieran de nuevo al barco aparecieron
los datos y esperamos 6 horas para que
se procesaran Y ahí estaba casi de
inmediato se podía ver que era un barco
estaba en dos partes a 500 metros de
distancia y entonces tuvimos la certeza
de que lo habíamos encontrado
este hallazgo sucede en vísperas de las
conmemoraciones del 25 de abril cuando
se celebra el Día de ansak para destacar
la memoria de todas las tropas muertas
de Australia y Nueva Zelanda durante
conflictos bélicos
y en Estados Unidos la Corte Suprema
decidió ayer viernes mantener el acceso
a la píldora abortiva mifepristrona el
tumbó así las restricciones impuestas
por un tribunal de apelaciones que
pretendía que esta pastilla usada en la
mitad la interrupciones voluntarias del
embarazo del país no pudiera recetarse
por ejemplo por telemedicina entregarse
por correo o usarse después de las siete
semanas de gestación se mantiene de
momento el acceso al medicamento pero la
batalla legal continúa la Corte Suprema
de mayoría conservadora que derogó hace
casi un año La sentencia de Robert sigue
evaluando la decisión de un juez de
Texas de prohibir por completo el
medicamento que la fda aprobó hace más
de 20 años
y con motivo del día de la tierra
hacemos ahora un repaso por algunas
noticias climáticas alrededor del mundo
alerta por temperaturas y fenómenos
climáticos extremos en Tailandia las
autoridades piden a los ciudadanos que
no realicen actividades al aire libre
durante el fin de semana dado Que las
temperaturas pueden superar los 40
grados Celsius en distintos puntos del
país como en la capital Bangkok
en el sur de Francia cientos de personas
se manifestaron en contra de la
construcción de una autovía entre kast y
toulouse los activistas denuncian que el
proyecto destruiría el medio ambiente y
que representa un modelo contrario a la
lucha climática
en Reino Unido centenares de personas
marcharon por las calles de Londres en
el marco de una protesta de cuatro días
convocada por extinción rebelión la
protesta se desarrolló en la zona
institucional de
exigir más acción política contra la
crisis climática
y las de Francia o de Reino Unido son
solo algunas de las acciones de protesta
que tuvieron lugar hoy en el día de la
tierra Gabriel colchen nos cuenta más
Hoy se celebra el Día de la tierra en
Perú varios chamanes se reunieron en la
capital Lima en víspera de la fecha para
rendir homenaje al planeta y crear
conciencias sobre la crisis climática
nos hemos reunido todos los maestros de
diferentes lugares de Costa sierra y
selva para hacer un ritual Místico
ancestral en agradecimiento a la tierra
que nos brinda todo lo que nosotros
consumimos lo que nosotros utilizamos y
para concientizar a la población a la
humanidad que tiene que tener un poco de
conciencia de no lograr mucha
contaminación a la tierra los efectos de
la contaminación global se reflejan en
el calentamiento del planeta según un
informe de la agencia meteorológica de
la ONU 2022 estuvo entre el quinto y
sexto año más cálido jamás registrado
como consecuencia el año pasado estuvo
marcado por dramáticos desastres
medioambientales como inundaciones en
Asia olas de calor mortal en Europa y
América
incesantes sequías en el cuerno de
África o intensas tormentas en
Norteamérica además el nivel del mar
también sube cada vez más rápido por el
derretimiento de los glaciares
el derretimiento de los glaciares
continúa y ha habido un aumento de
cuatro veces del derretimiento de los
glaciares desde los años 70 y aquí en
Suiza perdimos el 6,2% de la masa de los
glaciares el verano pasado debido a la
ola de calor lo que es un nuevo récord
los países y las grandes empresas
contaminantes todavía no han tomado
acción significativa para evitar un
mayor calentamiento global por lo tanto
la ONU advirtió que es cada vez más
probable que se supere el calentamiento
de 1,5 grados desde la era preindustrial
un límite acordado entre casi todos los
países del mundo en el acuerdo de París
en 2015
a ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención Nosotros llegamos así al final
de esta emisión pero enseguida
[Música]